OF MISINTERRUPTION.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
WITH MORE REACTION AUTHOR OF THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" BEST SELLER,
GREGG JARRETT AND REPORTER SARAH
CARTER AND THE HILL JOHN
SOLOMON.
SARAH AND JOHN, I WILL START
WITH YOU.
WHAT BOTH OF YOU AND CATHERINE
REPORTED TODAY IS YOU HAVE
McCABE AND LISA PAGE, WHEN ROD
ROSENSTEIN SAID HE WANTED TO
RECORD THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THIS WOULD BE
A PLOT AGAINST THE FIRING OF
JAMES COMEY WHICH HE
RECOMMENDED.
THEY EVER SAYING IT'S REAL.
ROSENSTEIN IS SAYING IT'S NOT
REAL.
WAS ONLY SARCASTIC.
TWO PEOPLE IN THE DEEP STATE.
WHO DO YOU BELIEVE?
>> THIS IS WHY WE HAVE TO COME
TO THE TRUTH.
SOMEBODY IS LYING HERE.
WE HAVE THE FORMER GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE FBI JAMES
BAKKER.
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT.
BAKKER DELIVERED THIS TESTIMONY
WITHOUT ANY EMOTION.
HE ABSOLUTELY 100% BELIEVED
ANDREW McCABE AND LISA PAGE.
EVEN MORE SHOCKING IS THAT THERE
ARE 2 OTHER PEOPLE WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION WHO WERE ON BOARD
WITH ROD ROSENSTEIN AND TRYING
TO INVOKE THE 25th AMENDMENT
SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT WAS
UNFIT FOR OFFICE.
THERE IS SOMETHING HAPPENING
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION.
ROD ROSENSTEIN HAS THOSE
ANSWERS.
THURSDAY WILL BE TELLING.
WILL HE SHOW UP AND ANSWER ALL
OF THESE QUESTIONS.
WHO IS ACTUALLY INVESTIGATING
THE INVESTIGATORS?
I SAY THIS OVER AND OVER.
IF ROD ROSENSTEIN IS IN CHARGE
OF SPECIAL COUNSEL OF THE
MUELLER INVESTIGATION, WHO IS IN
CHARGE OF ROD ROSENSTEIN?
HE IS IN THE MIDDLE OF ALL OF
THIS.
HE SIGNED THE FISA WARRANT ON
CARTER PAGE.
HE WROTE THE LETTER TO GIVE THE
PRESIDENT SO COMEY WOULD BE
FIRED.
HE IS IN THE MIDDLE OF
EVERYTHING AND SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
FIND OUT THE TRACT.
HE IS STILL THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL OF THE UNITED STATES.TR
THE UNITED STATES.
SEAN THIS SOUNDS LIKE A SOFT
COUP.
-- YOU HAVE 2 PEOPLE THAT BOTH
RECORDED THE SAME THING HERE
ABOUT WHAT ROD ROSENSTEIN SAID.
>> A FRIEND SAID I THINK THE FBI
NEEDS TO RENAME THEMSELVES.
MAYBE THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
POLITICS.
THERE WAS MORE POLITICS GOING.
>> Sean: THIS IS ONLY THE TOP
ECHLON.
>> NO, THEY ARE EMBARRASSED BY
THIS.
THEY DO THEIR JOB EVERY DAY.
IN THE MIDDLE OF RUSSIA, YOU
HAVE ONE TEAM DOING PROFESSIONAL
WORK AND THE OTHER TEAM
COLLUSION.
JAMES BAKER, 4 THINGS HE
REVEALED.
USED THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY LAWYER
AS A SOURCE.
THE FBI TRIED TO REDACT THAT.
HE USED A JOURNALIST AS A SOURCE
TO GET A VERSION OF THE DOSSIER
AFTER STEELE WAS FIRED AND HE
WAS PRESENT FOR A CONVERSATION
WHERE THE FBI PEOPLE WERE
SERIOUS ABOUT REMOVING THE
PRESIDENT AND RECORDING HIM ON
THE 25th AMENDMENT.
ALL 4 THINGS ARE POLITICS.
NONE INVOLVE LEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION.
>> Sean: AND EVERY PIECES GOES
BACK TO HILLARY CLINTON WHOM
THEY SAVED.
IT COMES BACK TO HER.
PHONEY RUSSIAN PAID FOR DOSSIER.
BEFORE THE ELECTION THEY LIED TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
AFTER THE RBIS  -- ELECTION,
THEY USED IT TO BLUDGEON DONALD
TRUMP AND SET UP AN ATMOSPHERE
WHERE A SPECIAL COUNSEL COULD BE
APPOINTED.
GREG YOU HAVE A COLUMN TOMORROW.
I WANT TO READ THE FIRST
PARAGRAPH TO OUR AUDIENCE.
YOU SAY TRUMP MAY HAVE GIVEN
THEM A PASS REFERRING TO THE
MEETING AT AIR FORCE ONE
YESTERDAY FOR NOW.
BUT AMERICANS SHOULD NOT AND
NEITHER SHOULD THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS WHO SEEMS
MISSING IN ACTION AND CLUELESS."
I CAN'T DISAGREE WITH THAT AND I
ALWAYS LIKED HIM.
>> ROSENSTEIN IS HOPELESSLY
COMPROMISED.
HE NOT ONLY HAS DISQUALIFYING
CONFLICTS OF INTEREST BECAUSE HE
IS A WITNESS IN THIS CASE OVER
WHICH HE PRESIDES!
YOU CAN'T BE A JUDGE AND THE
JURY AND A WITNESS AND THE
PROSECUTOR ALL ROLLED INTO ONE.
IT'S A VIOLATION OF FEDERAL
REGULATIONS.
IT DEMANDS HIS REMOVAL AND
RECUSAL.
BUT ON TOP OF IT NOW, THERE IS
NEW EVIDENCE AND 3 WITNESSES
THAT IN AN ACT OF VENGEANCE FOR
THE FIRING OF COMEY HE IS TRYING
TO SECRETLY RECORD THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES AND DEPOSE
HIM IN THE EQUIVALENT OF A
POLICY COUP.
THIS IS MISCONDUCT AND REQUIRES
HIS TERMINATION.
HE IS SUPPRESSING WRONGDOING BY
THE FBI AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND SUPPRESSING HIS OWN
WRONGDOING IN SIGNING OFF ON THE
FISA WARRANT.
>> Sean: SARAH AND JOHN, DO YOU
AGREE WITH THE CHARACTERIZATION?
I AGREE WITH GREGG.
I BELIEVE THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT TO
LITERALLY SET A PRESIDENT UP FOR
A SOFT COUP.
>> 100%, SEAN.
THERE IS OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE.
NOT JUST CIRCUMSTANCEAL.
WE HAVE SEEN IT IN RIGHTING AND
WITH TESTIMONY PROVIDED TO
CONGRESS.
THIS WAS A WHITE COUP, A SILENT
COUP.
A BLOODLESS COUP.
WHAT IS SO CONCERNING IS HOW
DANGEROUS THIS HAS BEEN TO
AMERICA AND HOW STILL IS TO THE
ADMINISTRATION.
IT NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.
>> THE SINGLE BIGGEST THREAT ROD
ROSENSTEIN FACES IS THE
MISLEADING OF THE FISA COURT.
DID HE MISLEAD THE FISA COURT?
>> Sean: WHO DO YOU BELIEVE?
McCABE AND PAGE OR ROD
ROSENSTEIN?
>> I WILL NEVER BELIEVE ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
HE HAS A LONG AND DISTINGUISHED
TRACK RECORD OF DEPOSITION.
>> YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL ALL OF
THE FACTS COME OUT.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD FROM ROD
ROSENSTEIN HIMSELF.
HE HAS TO PUT HIS RECORD ON IT.
>> I DON'T BELIEVE ANY OF THEM,
SEAN.
IT NEEDS TO BE INVESTIGATED.